[Music]
Yeehaw come on now is the Red Wave boys
we gonna get
Ron D scientists gonna be our next
president hell yeah hell yeah brother
yeah brother I got I got me this
oversized Mega hat but I'll tell you
what man
that Donald Trump is an albatross I've
seen that comment yeah unconservative
subreddit Donald Trump is an albatross
around our net gentlemen we are all
domestic terrorists
that Donald Trump that boy ain't right
that boy ain't right boy tell you what
man I've been saying that the whole time
now they're doing like that you might
not know this because you know you don't
have a Twitter but um the Republicans
lost actually like big time oh [ __ ]
right yeah not the yeah and actually not
to hurt your feelings but I am allowed
to lurk Twitter still oh okay that's
good my account is read only and that
where's Dan
you look like
you look like my five month old when he
wears a hat I can't
is the camera on me I can't see anything
by the way thank you to our sponsor day
doordash we love you we love you also an
announcement
quickly the teddy fresh Black Friday
sales live starting it just started 15
minutes ago damn 70 off a lot of [ __ ]
it's like 50 to 70 off most [ __ ]
things you guys it's absolutely it's
crazy time bending mind bending that's
crazy
yeah yeah it is and by the way
also this shirt's not on sale but you
have till Sunday to buy it Elon Musk is
a piece of [ __ ] I love that one thanks
bro and then actually finally we get to
uh plug
uh Hassan stuff I do yeah I have some I
normally don't but this is not one of
those instances
ideology.shop Robert Smith why the [ __ ]
did that just come out of my computer I
don't know what just click of the Cure
on that link Robert Smith of the Cure
Fame yeah I could love haste and it was
Robert Smith how's that what does that
even mean
how did that happen
you're a big cure Fan Man
okay let's try again there you go you
did it yeah
there's one of you guys using this
computer looking up cure fandom
what the hell what yes so uh
ideology.shop Hassan's himbo I'm still
waiting for my himbo [ __ ] Bro didn't I
send you a link yeah I filled out the
questionnaire and get my [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] I'll yell at my merch people
is your head gonna shrink if you wear
this no but your [ __ ] gains will be
tremendous okay okay you're gonna you at
least at least like 25 increase on your
PR straight up okay I don't believe
Hassan Ethan I I got some merch and this
is actually a regular size hat oh no his
head oh no this is awesome you got your
your people make the clothes [ __ ]
yeah that that is a really cool gift
yeah that has no business being that
cool honestly I don't even know I don't
even know where the [ __ ] that came from
yeah but anyway uh uh ideology.shop and
uh uh Hassan's himbo gym well we got a
lot to talk about today oh man wait what
happened well uh something big happened
yes
um
I got banned on Twitter yeah that's what
we're going to talk about right because
I
I haven't been paying a lot of attention
to anything else that's going on except
for the big news that I guess uh well I
I are you banned off Twitter because I
remember seeing you tweet something
about leftovers
like yesterday
no I'm banned no no I think you
definitely tweeted some yeah I saw I
thought you got them back you had an
announcement I thought you got unbanned
and you had an announcement that we were
gonna oh yeah you're talking about my
all
uh oh that's your all yeah oh that's
crazy Ethan H3 producatons
I love that Elon Musk is like we need we
have to prevent imposters impersonations
and now it's like and he clapped your
ass cheeks into Smithereens and now
everyone is parodying you yeah I know
but this guy's actually a fan we know
him I am unfortunately announcing
leftovers is officially ending with
peace and love Hassan it was a great run
Brother people actually thought it was
real a little yeah people immediately
did the thing like when Dan was leaving
uh the Asia issue production is
immediately coming into my chat and
being like dude what the [ __ ] yeah
leftovers over what the [ __ ] happened
I'm like what what is happening no it
was just protectants product Productions
got us again yeah just [ __ ] but like
I would be curious to see if Elon like
bans this account
because he's not disclosing it properly
right Dan the disclosure Nazi over here
again where where is the disclosure
supposed to be because I remember you
disclosed it I disclosed it in the
header in your name and in the info it
was not in my name it was oh that's
where you're supposed to disclose it as
a parody yes you need to disclose it in
every [ __ ] place you can possibly
right Elon Musk is like if you
impersonate me you have to literally
write like this legal text document
ahead of time on on every facet like uh
this is uh impersonation not liable to
uh slander and libel laws is parody
yeah but um except for that it seems
that he's only going after accounts that
uh targeting him which is interesting
but we're not here to talk about that
I've done enough talking about that
um I am here to talk about actually I'm
here to talk about this
what I forgot I prepared a segment about
it
um yeah yeah so ever since he's such a
[ __ ] idiot bro
um who Elon yeah he goes I'm we have to
add
verification for everybody to stop spam
yeah that was [ __ ] he just basically
look
he just wants to make more money but
he's a [ __ ] idiot and he's not doing
the smart thing to make more money this
is like really short-term gains Twitter
makes money off of daily active users
and the data that they sell off of daily
active users to advertisers if your
platforms moderation tools are in a
state of disarray advertisers are not
going to go to the new fronts and
upfronts and immediately sign off to
millions and millions of dollars in
Revenue to Twitter so he already is
cooked on that front because he shook
things up like I don't give a [ __ ] if
you you know eviscerate the board of
Executives right but like when you start
firing Engineers when you start firing
people they're doing the content
moderation and whatnot advertisers are
going to be like well that's crazy
especially when you're promoting
conspiracy theory simultaneously while
doing all this stuff so he's he's trying
to make like he's trying to max out on
on the short term side and uh he thinks
people will pay for this blue check mark
nobody's buying this back from him
Twitter is like a hot potato bro nobody
he's buying the [ __ ] back yeah but um
Rudy so here here's some of the great
examples have been happening in the past
24 hours a fake Rudy Giuliani account
and what's great is they'll make a new
account
and Nancy Pelosi and I do not agree on
many things but them things thing and I
tell you what that's the most truthful
Rudy Giuliani has ever been he's
preaching man
I stand with Kyrie I uh Iving and Kanye
West because George shorts once pushed
me down in the street and I was stuck on
my back like a turtle that's crazy that
that actually happened
this is a verified account I have no way
of understanding dude this seems like
Rudy Giuliani and look it I mean it's
similar to his real name yeah uh I am
hereby issuing a challenge to Alan dersh
Street beefs come get some derps that
can only be one Dusty old pedophile that
turned me around that's crazy
um congratulations on Rudy for openly
admitting that though that's that's bold
and brave it's nice to see that out open
uh he's going after Helen Keller who I
would admit deserves it Helen Keller's a
Dusty fraudulent [ __ ] pushed on us by
globalist media
I couldn't agree more frankly wow your
auntie you're Auntie yeah tell me who
cares you can't talk we had a whole she
had a whole Arc about this yeah how do
you know
what do you mean what it's like
documented she couldn't talk and she
couldn't see bro she was a socialist but
how do we even know she understood what
the things that were going around her
you can communicate even if you can't
like wasn't she wasn't she born deaf and
blind or was that she became deaf and
blind I don't know yeah I just know that
she's a socialist and I think she might
have been a eugenesis too though so yeah
canceled again never mind boom you know
it's like with Kellen Keller it's like
you know how with gorillas you're like
they you could teach him sign and you're
like but do they really know what
they're doing it's the same thing
absolutely eviscerated by the disability
activist for stating this oh we've been
down this road many times before
actually what you have an Auntie Helen
Keller Crusade it's like so such a weird
phone to pick that's why that's why it's
so funny yeah but you know what how many
people are deaf and blind watching the
show like that's like Helen Keller don't
owe me anything nobody no they wouldn't
know they wouldn't be able to watch this
show I know but ninety percent of the
time when people are chirping at you
they don't even have that disability
it's just like other people being like
I'm gonna be talking on behalf of this
community right now say what you will
but I'm against Helen Keller and I
always will be it's good it's good that
you you know you pick your battles
what's that Mother Teresa yeah mother
tree she has it coming too actually it
turns out she is actually a really awful
person there's like new you heard about
this right no she like tortured she she
was like a horrible person people are
discovering not surprising like uh she
was taking care of uh like lepers and
[ __ ] or like super sick people and she
wasn't giving them medicine or treating
them because she's like you you're
suffering will bring you closer to God
you are definitely getting canceled now
you attacked an Albanian woman it's over
oh and Bailey and baleophobia
um yeah so there's just a lot of this
and then you see uh I love this he says
what did you think was gonna happen Ben
Shapiro Matt Walsh won't stop calling me
and talking about genitalia but that's
real though but that like that's like a
fake account but that is a real thing
that happens all the time Matt Walsh
cannot shut the [ __ ] up he's always like
what is a woman please tell me I need to
know do you have a [ __ ] or a dick
please I need to look I need to look let
me take a picture let me take a gander
like that's that's Matt Walsh does
straight up how he is dude Matt Walsh is
the worst person in the world and I you
he was on Joe Rogan you know Joe Rogan
did get him pretty good
but um I have not seen it yet he got
actually pull up a clip Joe Joe
definitely eviscerated him on a couple
of points but ultimately I think that's
an L having that [ __ ] guy yeah
because he's like dude I love what you
have to say about trans people it's so
sick
all my friends are like damn dude what
is a woman for real dude what's a woman
bro
yeah I've been on him for like gay
marriage right like that's it gay
marriage well also that what she
definitely annihilated on but that's
like so easy but the one that um I saw
was Matt Walsh was like there's millions
of pre-pubescent children getting
puberty blockers and she was like really
really what though and then Jamie's like
actually it's a thousand it was very it
was very I I wait okay I'll just say
this I'll just say this I talked about
this before on my stream but um I'm
gonna I'm publicly I'm soft launching it
but I'm hard launching it eventually I
think
people who say like being trans is a
mental illness have an unironic
undiagnosed mental illness called what I
call Turf brain like when you got Trans
on the mind and it gets to a certain
point where like it literally you just
live and breathe Tran like you were
thinking about trans people and what
they're [ __ ] doing way more than
trans people are yeah yeah so I think
that that is the real mental illness you
know that's a good point Matt Walsh it's
like his whole [ __ ] yeah he's like
obsessed with you Lance what's the
[ __ ] bomb Children's Hospitals
because he's like there's trans people
there and the thing is well here here
they don't want so uh if a trans person
stubs their [ __ ] toe and and they get
medical treatment Matt was gonna [ __ ]
hear about it and he's gonna talk about
it on a stream okay he's gonna direct
his his psychotic zealots to go and and
you know send mailbombs there or some
[ __ ] for the crime of treating a trans
person and that's insane like you
yo it
this is going to tie back into the
election a little bit and I'm gonna I
this is one of my favorite subjects to
talk about now is that like they went
too far
okay the pubs you're crazy yeah you're
too crazy yeah nobody wants to associate
with like that level of crazy it's
actually so refreshing because because
you know I was feeling very Bleak very
black filled because you see people like
Marjorie Taylor green who was reelected
Lo and bobert who Stan we'll see if she
wins or not but it's so [ __ ] close
they're gonna recount it and a lot of
these other super radical Maga election
denying freaks are getting annihilated
and I think Trump really has become a
bad Omen for them
um I think they went too far but it's
not Donald Trump as I always say it's
just the Republican party we can talk
about it further let's watch this real
quick
um let's watch this [ __ ] psychopath
yeah Matt Walsh is an actual like
hateful bigoted Psychopathic freak yeah
he's just like he's just benches sweaty
pervert he's so disgusting he looks like
when I wear these glasses he looks like
me if I got bludgeoned in the face with
a shovel and like lost my hairline
completely
well you know what they say I'm I've
been absorbing his hairline for years so
yeah you absorb all of our enemies
hairlines and I took a little of yours
too yeah that's kind of just collateral
damage please let me get it back please
friendly fire
I don't think we have exact numbers but
it's if we're talking about you
destroyed Joe I mean oh Joe is
annihilated
his soul like a goddamn yeah that um
boss
thank you baby thank you
um do you talk about hormone blockers
yeah but millions of kids have been on
hormone blockers really uh
I'm sure someone's going to fact check
me on me but my my guess is that we're
in we're into the millions now at this
point by the way this clip starts like
he had already confidently asserted
there's millions of kids on on puberty
blockers and remember he seems a little
unsure he's the foremost authority he
made the documentary what is a woman
this guy lives and breathes for this
[ __ ] surprising that uh you know mister
I know everything about trans people I
have the directory I have the documents
uh is is just so oblivious 100 he
watches transporn
oh without a doubt for research so many
so many of these people are Chasers so
many of these people fetishize trans
people and I think like that's where
part of that hatred comes from is
literally like them not being
comfortable with that
uh within themselves which is weird
you'd be like a better person if you
just gave up but he goes it's their
fault that I'm feeling this confused
they shouldn't exist
anyway my guess
um uh I I can say
for double mastectomies the most I've
read a report recently that no you
didn't there were over a thousand done
between 2016 and 2019. okay he's
actually being truthful in that one 2016
to 2019 three years there was a thousand
double mastectomies in a country of over
300 million people that's crazy they
should stop that what's that as
expressed as a percentage like .000 like
how [ __ ] in this fuel is that it's
[ __ ] up also infinitely higher uh
success rate as far as like happiness in
the aftermath of uh a a gender affirming
surgery in comparison to plastic surgery
in general which Matt Walsh does not
give a [ __ ] about you know these
[ __ ] don't care uh when when
you know
their wives are getting bigger boobs or
when uh Rhonda
gets liposuction on his neck did you see
that you do that uh there was some there
was I saw some Tick Tock about it and I
want to believe it I know my rule of
thumb is like never believe anything on
Tick Tock is it a plastic surgeon like
one of those no it was some I don't know
I mean maybe he he looked like the dude
who was talking was like
he looked like Giga Chad a little bit so
I was like that made it more suspicious
for me but anyway let's just let's work
through this we got so much to get to
Matt just [ __ ] say your [ __ ] and
let's move the [ __ ] on you freak ass I
can't I can't tell if you're talking to
Matt or me right now no I'm [ __ ]
impossible
love you and when you compare that to
how many were done between you know 2008
and 2015 it's just it's a massive
increase and uh it's so I'm sorry but
it's like yeah bro it's becoming more
accepted stop shut the [ __ ] up yeah I
mean that's the whole there's a whole
[ __ ] stupid you guys know that though
you're so idiot that's why he's relevant
like that that's the whole [ __ ] he wants
to stop it being normalized stop it we
need to flatten the curve again actually
he wants to go back to reducing the
amount of gay people anyways
over a thousand girls gender affirming
double mastectomies in that in that time
frame girls you're talking about
prepubes right minors uh and that's just
up until 2019 and then we know that
there's been this exponential increase
with all this stuff year over year so
um it's just imagine dedicating your
whole life to something that happened a
thousand times over three years
well I mean it's it's the same old
schtick like even the Utah governor was
like come on guys we need to remember
when the Utah the governor Utah was like
I'm not passing this [ __ ] bill
there's one there was in the history of
Utah there was one trans 12 year old who
attended a [ __ ] swim meet and you
guys passed through the state
legislature of Bill Banning trans people
like the [ __ ] are you doing no and
that's usually what it is that's usually
what it is it's literally like maybe one
trans girl that is like attended a swim
meet in 1997 and these guys are like
yeah we gotta we gotta make sure they're
all dead yo this guy's based bro that's
no it's not come on no but like this is
kind of dope that he stood up to this
bro I mean it's nice don't don't come on
bro he's the Utah Governor this was a
based move on his part you're out here
[ __ ] I really appreciate when I see
people oh you found it Abe gurko won't
be silent look look at the take
jumping around
it's a lot it's too many you know one
having this happen to one can you
imagine just one yeah look if you're in
just one makes what I'm doing worthwhile
understand who you are and what you are
and this is how you feel you should
progress you're an adult this is a free
country you should be able to do
whatever you want
but when you're talking what if you're a
six-year-old and you're suicidal
these guys are so funny because like
they make it seem like there's some
titty doctor out there who's like oh
yeah 16 year old come in Chop Chop like
sick the titty butcher yeah there's like
first of all there's a tremendous amount
of paperwork that you go through there's
like medical evaluations psych
evaluations for adults that is like
double tripled quadrupled when it comes
down to uh miners it's not allowed to
enter consent and like the most extreme
yeah there's parental understand there's
like multiple avenues that you need to
go down and there's no no bottom surgery
whatsoever only top uh and and even then
it's like super super low numbers and
you can't do it for anyone under the age
of 16 anyway it's like 16 to 18 is what
they are freaking out about I think
there's more people getting struck by
lightning than who are getting double
mastectomies probably under 18. yeah
because like the number of trains how
many people are getting struck by
lightning in America on a yearly basis
genuinely uh there the the number of
trans people is already low right I mean
it's probably higher than we think
because you know
because of [ __ ] like Matt Walsh but
um you know this is a this is
never going to be like this major
mainstream thing like you're just hyper
focusing on some of the most
marginalized people in society because
you're a [ __ ] making their life like
where you're a freak Loser yeah check
this out so in 2021
there was
basically 80 lightning strikes are
recorded So I mean I mean we're talking
about 300 a year of uh double mastectomy
so it's pretty close it's pretty close I
think we need to work we need to do
something with all these lightning
strikes bro no we need to we need to
yeah we need to work on the lightning I
want to intervene on that lightning
needs to start striking twice
[ __ ] what is this only only 70
80 you get those numbers up like I
propose that we need to and we need to
uh install metal poles every 100 yards
across the whole country ah come on bro
jump scare warning Jesus all right we're
almost made it through one [ __ ] clip
I'm not doing that to Children the fact
that so many people are on board and so
many people are angry if you have like
people are going to be angry at us that
we're having these conversations
you [ __ ] you know that it's not that
you're having the conversation that's
not why people are mad you [ __ ] you
idiot
yeah the conversation revolves around
the doxing of trans individuals and also
uh you know lying instructions
instructions on how to send a letter
bomb to children's hospitals in Boston
you know that's just a conversation
yeah they don't do that but yeah I mean
it's like having Hitler on being like
or even Kanye West at this point and
being like yeah that's interesting what
you're saying about the Jews let me see
that red list again
now they're gonna get angry that we're
even discussing this I actually think
that now uh that this should this
shouldn't be happening to here here it
is here it is doesn't go sideways for
him a very small number if that's right
it says over the last five years there
were at least 4 780 adolescents who
started puberty blockers and at a prior
gender dysphoria diagnosis wait that's
but that's gender no no that's puberty
blockers you said there was Millions
that's not even [ __ ] uh mastectomies
he said there's millions of people so so
here yeah that's [ __ ] that would be
a big one a thousand people a year yeah
we got him yeah I mean I I would guess
you know hundreds of thousands at this
but I could be wrong
you could be wrong you're the expert bro
what is it yeah sounds great
[ __ ] should I ask what is Google
bro what is this you know what Joe
Rogan's a little [ __ ] [ __ ] for not
like making that a bigger deal right
like he let him off oh look at his face
no no he likes it though he like he's
like yeah I know I know but he's not
about you but like the obvious follow-up
is like you are the expert you made a
documentary how do you not know that it
depends on what yeah which he hyped by
the way he was like all of my friends
love this documentary they're always
asking what is a woman it's like you're
a [ __ ] dude you're a [ __ ] okay you are
it's just a self-report when you're like
all of my friends are like what is a
woman guess what [ __ ] if all of
your friends are asking what is a woman
then you're probably going to be one of
those people that thinks there's gonna
be a major [ __ ] Red Wave Okay
the reason why he was like oh the Red
Wave is coming he's gonna be like The
Shining why because these guys have lost
their minds they're like everyone's a
gender sicko you know kids are [ __ ]
[ __ ] and pissing in litter boxes at
a certain point at a certain point when
your brain is so [ __ ] broken by like
watching Matt Walsh and like watching
all these [ __ ] conservative freaks
that you know the the Norman adults in
the suburbs and [ __ ] who are probably
way more open-minded to uh LGBT stuff
given their proximity you know what I
mean because like there's always going
to be
within the Gen z uh within the next
Generation there's like there's gay kids
there's trans kids you know what I mean
they're like a lot more open
to that sort of thing so you're always
going to have at least like one parent
at the parent Teachers Conference who's
like no my kid is gay or my kid is trans
like shut the [ __ ] up that uh makes them
infinitely more open-minded and not as
hostile towards uh trans things as as uh
these guys are so that's one element of
it and then the other side is like
you're constantly saying like these guys
are pedophiles pedophile groomers
pedophile groomers like well you run
into the uh the the anti-pedophile uh
like the the pedo Hunters you run into
the pedo Hunter's uh Dynamic there where
like they're kind of weird too you know
what yeah yeah you know what I'm talking
about the guy who busted EDP is like a
[ __ ] super weirdo yeah it's like yo
you you're like really [ __ ] really
invested in this like it's kind of weird
like you're constantly talking about
pedophiles and [ __ ] like nobody wants to
be around I live and breathe pedophilia
yeah nobody wants to be around someone
who is like insanely cringe lost the
plot sounds like the crazy person at the
[ __ ] subway station regularly uh
chirping about like trans people or or
how like all the teachers are [ __ ]
pedophile groomers you know you know
what happened if you don't know what a
woman is just say the only correct
answer just say hey I just got here
anyway let's watch uh something
important to talk about his son uh did
Ron DeSantis get neck fupa reduction I'm
gonna tell me that Rhonda santis didn't
have a lipo before her big performance
last night that was a couple weeks ago
that was last night
I mean I mean okay uh that could just be
a flatter unflattering but yeah there's
that's a that's I just want to believe
man it's fun it's fun to [ __ ] believe
in fake [ __ ] with that realize their
gender I guess it's not gender affirming
it's just no it is it is a fine jawline
oh it is a masculine thing Elon Musk
getting hairline surgery that's gender
affirming 100 percent
Joe Rogan being on trt it's literally
hormone replacement therapy like that is
the most mind-boggling thing is like I
learned about trt from Joe Rogan I'm an
old Joe Rogan head I even have the
[ __ ] mug I've been listening to this
dude talking about divorce court for
like [ __ ] 15 years now okay it's not
fair right yeah he is the biggest
advocate for trt he got me invested in
potentially getting on trt when I'm like
35 and my T levels start declining right
and this [ __ ] has made the tail
end of his career [ __ ] on other
people that want to get trt or HRT in
general like that's crazy yeah yeah he
doesn't see it
um so there's one more thing before
obviously we're gonna talk about the
midterms that's the main thrust of the
episode here and there's lots of good
stuff to get to maybe we should just get
to it because we're going to run out of
time
but like is he a troll I wasn't it I
mean no you're a [ __ ] idiot let me
just open this one video Let's just
because this guy apparently he's a
serious person we're never getting to
the [ __ ] by Nick Adams he's a serious
person and I asked you Dan like 20 I was
like this is not a joke this is real is
this realism or is he kidding I I can't
tell because he's so brain broken man
and he can go either way you know what I
mean I feel like he leans into it a
little bit though
this guy he's a conservative commentary
guy
and uh he's obsessed with Hooters of
really oh he's obsessed with a lot of
[ __ ] he's he he's PFD comments
commenter's favorite character on
Twitter too but he he's got an important
message with peace and love breasts good
idea
family establishment and all for one am
absolutely sick and tired of it being
defined
no no no don't you defame the accent is
fake right no he's Ozzy oh he's an
awesome what yeah this entire time he
was Australian yeah [ __ ] has USA
on his name yep bro I never listen to
him dog I've only read his tweets and
every time I read his tweets I'm doing
like in my head I'm assuming he's like
one of those like sausage men you know
what I mean he just sounds so like
Midwestern or something right no but
he's an Aussie he's a good he's all down
under down under we like respect titties
he looks so he looks oh he's one of
those guys he's like a Marabou kind of
like Ian miles wrong yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's like bro you're in Malaysia
like shut the [ __ ] up talk about
Malaysian news
is the worst
introduced and mocked used as a tool to
stop men being men used as a tool to
stop their being well he's gonna break
me when I find out he's got some Turk in
him or something because he looks kind
of Turkish too
there's a lot of Turks in Australia
this attack on Hooters will not stand oh
my God it's an attack on masculine I've
never thought about Hooters for the
record bro like I don't think about
Hooters if you take your kids to Hooters
a little [ __ ] weird though bro I'm
just going to be screaming I mean I'm
not running the Hooters I loved it when
I was a kid I'll be honest did you go to
Hooters
[ __ ] I'm not gonna reveal any names
[ __ ] I'm not gonna reveal any names yes
the Hooters
but it was sick I mean okay it was dope
I was like 14. it was fire okay all
right I'm not a kill man I'm happy for
you breasts
like I wouldn't make it a policy though
I'm not like you have to take your
children there or you know whatever
it's not that bad even like it's not
they just wear like tight shirts yeah
not even it's real yeah it's not
revealing at all oh I guess they just
hide
they're shorts too yeah I mean it's just
a normal restaurant with skimpy uniforms
in the age of only fans like the Hooters
is not even a question like no one no
one is thinking like oh man I'm gonna
get my rocks off of Hooters like I used
to jerk off analog you know what I mean
I needed a [ __ ] magazine yeah like
I'm old
brooter's titties was like all you got
dude we used to get we used to have to
go get like the 25 cent we're so Duty
mag and you know what we really had to
do we heard there was a nudie mag in the
[ __ ] river bottom and we have to go
hike around and find it yes and we did
find it yes dude that's like levels of
horny that you can't imagine by the way
we sound so over like I used to walk up
there both sides for three miles to find
a titty pick I'd dead bro oh my God
that's crazy kids these days don't know
they don't know I drew my own titties to
jerk off to see that I never that's like
that's pretty brave okay I had to draw
my own hentai are you a good artist
because I never was good enough I was
yeah I that's how I learned how to draw
women like I I could only draw like
dudes and then I was like I need to
learn how to draw women he's like I'm in
a drought there's no there's nothing to
jerk off to I've heard of other people
doing that but I don't think so yeah in
this in that day and age like you know
seeing a Hooters waitress like that kept
me going for like months you know what I
mean I banked that you know what I mean
there wasn't a crime when that was an
important service yes
now who cares like that's crazy I did
scrambled cable porn too yeah oh yeah
and it that that was that was desperate
time yeah that scrambled porn of course
you have to time it you have to time it
too like when your parents are away you
know what I mean so like you don't know
when they're gonna come back from dinner
so you have to do like it's it's you
know it's one of those you're like was
that a titty or an elbow you're like
stare you're standing right in front of
the television like this should I should
I should I finish is that a elbow or
yeah is it a bald head is it you can't
get caught like I had oh my God I had
the moveset like ready you know what I
mean immediately like flip the waistband
back up you have to hit the [ __ ] TV
like to you know Nickelodeon or whatever
you need them six to midnight you need
an Escape Plan always bro like God
forbid you hear that key turning oh my
god dude it's over you ever been caught
[ __ ] yeah really see I'd never I oh my
God yeah I got caught by so I mean this
is real like affluent uh uh child
behavior but we had an au pair
what the [ __ ] when I was in Turkey it's
like a like a fancy way to say like a
living babysitter are you was your
family rich in Turkey yeah oh really
yeah they lost all their money by the
time I got uh by the time I was 18 but
they were my uh my family is very
wealthy wait when we're growing up let
me come from what where'd their money
come from
um my dad was the coordinator to like
one of the largest holding groups in the
country
it's a big firm he's like a mega firm
um anyway so what's a holding company
Holding Group is just like it's
basically like an Umbrella Corporation
that owns a bunch of other gigantic
corporations okay so he's a big he's a
big corporate he's like a big shot
corporate guy how do you lose his money
uh Futures Trading I think oh no yeah
dude I have a friend with a Le with a um
with a uh Lebanese dad who also lost his
entire family's Fortune to the same
[ __ ] thing is that a thing that
happens well I mean I guess it's uh we
we were that's the uguru and [ __ ]
family curse like every every single one
of my uh every generation like my
grandfather on my father's side super
wealthy spends all the money retires by
like 30 spends all of his money this
entire life so by the time my father was
by the time my father went to college
they didn't have a lot of money
he made a lot of money again Lost It All
by the time uh I went to college [ __ ] he
basically gambled it all the way yeah it
means
yeah you pissed at him for that was the
face was there problems in the family no
I don't give a [ __ ] no I haven't really
mad at him I had it I had an incredibly
fortunate incredibly privileged uh I
don't need disclaimers I just want to
know what actually happened were you oh
no I'm not but I'm but this is something
I talk about quite frequently like I and
it's important to my world view too it's
like why would I be mad at them they
already gave me the the [ __ ] major
boost ahead of time you know what I mean
for losing all the money no it's his
money made it really that's crazy
um I've never I've never cared about
that has he ever been on Wall Street
bets the subreddit you fit right in
there no this was in Turkey he should
post his losses bro they'd love that
[ __ ] yeah no this was this was in Turkey
but um wait what the [ __ ] was it what
were we talking about oh yeah I got
caught by my old pair okay that's not as
bad as she's like younger too she was
like younger yeah um
yeah I thought so oh [ __ ] that that what
did she do that was formative how old
were you oh
and then she ran away like she opened
the door I was like no so it's not like
in the porn
what she wasn't like no it wasn't like
in the porn at all just make it just
checking it was like it was a moment
where like it was terrifying for me but
then like that moment definitely fed me
a little bit oh my God I have the great
love you are ahead of the curve on the
on the oh [ __ ] yeah wait so how old were
you [ __ ] I don't know I was like 14.
younger probably even younger than 14
like 12 13 I don't know and it and when
you first next saw her it was what you
guys just kind of never acknowledged it
I mean what do you say about it never
yeah never talked about it what do you
mean I'm 12. what am I gonna do um we
need to talk about yeah yeah no I don't
know she maybe she say something like
please lock your door next time or
something I don't know I can't what do
you mean you think I would have locked
my door by the option no luck no we're
not American man they don't let what
Turkish children there's no door locking
that was fun
let's go have lunch well that's why you
have the lock I don't I just don't want
to walk see my kid jerking off
you know what I mean
I also didn't have we had a family
computer that was downstairs in the
[ __ ] living room yeah yeah that
sucked too yeah I didn't even have the
luxury of that until High School
yeah I know that pain yeah and you
didn't have like mobile phones that you
could just like immediately pull porn on
right
um kids these days don't no they don't
know the one time I got caught was
actually it was I was so young dude I
must have been like oh so you did get
caught but the story is kind of funny I
don't know I may have told this once on
the show far
I think I was like eight like I think I
had just I mean I started like humping
the bed and figuring out that felt good
so one time I was I stole one of my
dad's playboys and I was humping the bed
and I fell asleep
[Music]
and then I woke up and my mom was in the
room just like fixing up I was there my
pants were at my ankles
you ready
covers over you no I was out in the open
[ __ ] me and I woke up and my mom is
there just like pictures that was going
on how do you not I mean I was like yeah
maybe she didn't maybe I was too young
she would think that maybe that's crazy
but like I she was just there like
cleaning up and sorting [ __ ] and I was
like what the [ __ ] I think there was
someone else in there too I forget who
no almost I was so glad I would cover
the midterms extensively so far
on the most slammed midterms focused
episode we're talking about jerk off
stories from our childhood yeah [ __ ] it
they all know what happened all right
[ __ ] yeah I'm not listening to this
Hooters guys anymore let's get into it
oh yeah we got to do a break and then
we'll get it too and then we'll get into
the middle oh my God yeah important
well thank you to doordash by the way
who we love I love doordash man they
keep my ass fed boy yes yes sir
you got it back-to-back meetings Aaron's
running chores to take care of what's
the secret to clearing your to-do list
it's a little help from doordash you can
get dinner household essentials and
everything on your grocery list
delivered
along with the restaurants you love you
can now get groceries and other
essential items delivered with doordash
get drinks snacks and other household
items another an hour I love doing that
what sometimes you forget an ingredient
and you know everyone's like what are we
gonna do and it's like I got it doordash
sour that's my that's my move if I go to
like a party every party can be spiced
up with some with some burgers oh really
you bring Burgers wherever you go I'll
just go and I'll order like I'll order
so much food that's awesome yeah
doordash Burgers yeah pizza and it's
like you're the king now dude
immediately if you have if you have the
financial security to do so you know
yeah do it people will remember that oh
yeah every time you place an order for
pickup or delivery you're sitting off a
chain reaction that helps give back to
the people who make your neighborhood
great okay people helping people yeah
yeah with over 300 000 Partners you can
support your neighborhood go-to's or
choose from your favorite National
chains like Popeyes Chipotle Cheesecake
Factory and with doordash you're not
just getting the things you love but
supporting the community you love too
that's nice that's a beautiful message
huh that's a wonderful Joe's talk Taco
Shack just put his kid through college
uh what is this Mario's Pizzeria
just uh [ __ ] uh paid for his
electricity bill I don't know what that
it's some kind of it's a cable concealer
oh yeah put it away supposed to be
concealed tiny little ball gag
and listen to this from the stores and
restaurants to the Dasher drivers going
around each purchase provides a new
opportunity for everyone involved
because doordash there's a neighborhood
of good in every order
also you can get [ __ ] for a limited time
our listeners can get up to 50 off up to
a twenty dollar value and zero delivery
fees when you download the doordash app
and enter the code left over that's
actually an insane offer that's just 23
bucks yeah that's 50 off up to a 20
value and zero dollars in delivery fees
when you download the doordash app in
the app store and enter the code
leftovers don't forget that's code left
over for up to 50 off and up to a 20
value and zero delivery fees with
doordash subject subject to change terms
apply
thank you doordash I love doordash
that's a good one love them that's free
money guys free money
uh you know are you a fan of elong ma oh
this is my favorite
he's my favorite oh he's gonna call in
the show we got a hold of him oh no and
he speaks only Mandarin like it's all
real yeah so so Zach reached out to him
and he wrote him back in Mandarin Zach
had to translate it so we're working on
finding a mandarin translator
we got a couple okay good oh that's so
there's a little bit there's a there's a
new arc there's a there's a little bit
of an update that I think you'll
actually find quite interesting with all
that tell me uh he wants us to pay him
how much oh well I keep asking him
money he's literally doing the money
thing to us yeah
yeah okay he does so give me money
touch with uh it translated to his
broker what nobody broken his head bro
I've been talking to his manager
whatever the [ __ ] I think it probably
means manager yeah so um he wants to be
paid tell me how much bro I'll call it
up
I asked him like five times how much do
you want he's like present me offer oh
he's a very he's playing Hardball yeah
he also said something to the effect of
uh you need me more than I need you
he's such a better businessman than Elon
Musk it's true it's true yo crazy this
is awesome these guys are playing so
hard ball they are just be so maybe we'd
just be like yo you're I'm very sorry
you're so right we're desperate but I
don't know I don't know 100 bucks I
don't know I'm not I don't really think
it's worth more than that
crazy how do you put a price on that I
don't know I'm not paying him a thousand
dollars
so a hundred dollars maybe I'd pay more
let's start the negotiations there and
see okay okay how much is that and
what's that in China this man is a Titan
of Industry oh yeah he's like Mommy dude
I love him I love him so much
wait what's the Chinese currency I don't
even know it's uh like Yuan I believe
yeah so so I'll tell him in yuan's bro
what that are are a hundreds well he was
asking USD no yen is Japan
yeah
dude that's 718 [ __ ] Yuans bro okay I
will what are you on if you say no oh
nice worth more he's a king we're
starting negotiations I'm doing business
now I'm playing Hardball with me we're
going to do a little negotiating so yeah
okay I will message him back
I love that he said you need me more
than I know that's so [ __ ] funny he's
right he doesn't even know like what
he's calling into or what it is it could
just be like and I've been having to
talk to this guy what's gonna happen
he's gonna get canceled in [ __ ]
whatever region he lives about right
it's funny for all he knows it could
just be like some like two listener like
look at this this message show your
sincerity and say how much you can pay
we are no short of traffic we don't need
you to help us we need you to bring
quotation and then he said a Pepe Emoji
he's a dead people no yo that's fire
what kind of Pepe emotion it was like
the half-assed smile and it's the smirk
yeah the smirk where's like fingers wow
I'll bring a thousand Yuan how much is
that one thousand uh one thousand yuan
is the USD you want to know you want 145
40 bucks you want to know the truth yeah
elong Ma is the reason why Elon bought
Twitter so we could finally destroy like
it's like a Highlander right like he's
the real Elon ma is the real one right
and Elon is the fake one and he's
working actively to destroy him and
that's why he's like going hard after
impersonators I could be I mean yeah
that's why you got banned because of
elong mom
by the way Black Friday sales up thank
you teddyfresh.com
yeah we got it Segway we need to make
some money so we can pay
I'm about to go into the Yi long ma fund
I'm about to Shell out a thousand Yuan
all right let's talk let's talk shop
yeah we only have an hour left though
yeah let's get into it so first of all
the one thing I noticed that I want to
get your take on
and I love this it's so refreshing and
it's so nice very very very little talk
about rigged elections yeah and that's
so nice because
you know that's kind of the the
expectation these days yeah and uh it
didn't happen what's your take on that
um I think one of the things that
happened is Pennsylvania started
immediately uh tabulating uh early votes
like vote the the mail-in ballots like
the day of which they originally stated
they were not going to do which was
going to create what is known as the red
Mirage right and we were gearing up for
that the media was gearing up for that
everyone was like listen we need to
communicate this to you like
um even the Republicans actually engaged
in this on the other side where they
were like yeah it's gonna be real
strange when the Republicans are winning
at night and then the you know tide
turns around if that happens like
remember there's cheating and that
didn't happen it was a back and forth it
was neck and neck in many races and by
the end of the night
it looked like Democrats were winning in
a lot of places where they were not uh a
lot of places that were supposed to be
contested so for that reason they tried
it a little bit in Arizona and
Pennsylvania in Pennsylvania they ran
out of uh paper
and in Arizona I'm not on a paper I
don't know some dumb [ __ ] but um in
Arizona no more ballots people go home
in Arizona in Maricopa County uh there
were some issues with uh with one of the
processors that was just spitting out 75
percent of the ballots back only reading
25 percent okay so they were like please
use ballot drop off box number three and
then because these guys are especially
in Arizona the conservatives are so
geared they made it like a fundamental
plank of their campaigning that the
elections were stolen because of these
inconsistencies and stuff like that even
though there were no inconsistencies
a lot of these guys were terrified and
they cooked themselves they ended up
hurting themselves it ended up working
as voter suppression for their own base
of Voters yeah
um it literally backfired in a dramatic
way so other than those two instances we
haven't really heard too much Nevada is
still going to probably be an issue
there's going to be oh there's always
problems with Nevada uh in in tabulation
and whatnot it takes a long time uh same
with Arizona it's just a lot of these
like desert country they just don't know
how to count the the the heat just you
know wrecks people's brains I think yeah
yeah it just have a really hard time
with counting
um so we'll see what happens there
but uh overall I think it was because
they were ready for a massive Wipeout
which is understandable so but wouldn't
they want to scream Foul Play since they
didn't get what they wanted but I think
what you're saying there was less red
Mirage which is kind of gives them the
Optics yeah
there was less red Mirage and right now
they are too busy trying to comprehend
exactly how this gigantic [ __ ] up
happened for the Republican party
looking to pick up 60 seats in the House
barely barely winning the majority we
don't even know it may not even I was
yeah which is insane
yeah I think most of the predictions are
still leaning uh Republican right but
it's not it's not even a shot impossible
for them to fall short yeah
and it's it's not just crazy because
because
uh you know oh Republicans are really
doing well or whatever this is historic
and the reason why it's historic is you
know if I put my wonk hat on for a
second
every single time there's a president
that is like below 50 approval rating in
the midterms is going to get shafted his
party is going to get shafted Americans
use the midterms the ones that actually
end up going out and voting in the
midterms use it as an opportunity to say
we don't like what you're doing and if
your performance indicates that you know
people are not too happy with it as Joe
Biden's performance and his approval
rating after it you know boosted a
little bit was still resembling the
Donald Trump approval rating in the 2018
midterms you're slated to lose you know
60 plus seats that's normal yeah then on
top of that there's eight percent
inflation the cost of living is a crisis
a lot of people are losing their minds
over it in an understandable fashion
side note the economy is looking bad
impossible it looked like an impossible
win for any president doesn't matter if
it was Joe Biden doesn't matter if it
was Donald Trump doesn't matter if it
was Barack Obama any president in that
circumstance regardless of how many
great things they might may or may not
have done
they're gonna get destroyed apparently
it was the best turnout for an incumbent
president in decades yeah so um I think
it's encouraging I hope that we see less
of this uh rigged election [ __ ] which is
just scary and [ __ ] up and I think
Amer I'm proud of Americans because they
rejected that
and what's funny is we learned that the
strategy is actually self-defeating
because your [ __ ] fans lose faith in
the institution or your you know voters
and then they don't end up [ __ ]
voting even if they don't lose faith in
the institutions
if your goal is to get everybody to vote
on the day of
well you're advocating for voter
suppression for your own fan base
because like ultimately it's
significantly easier to vote and drop
off your you know mailed in ballot when
voting is easier more people vote yes
period absolutely which is something
that the Republicans truly understand
that's precisely why for a very long
time they were against mail-in voting
that's why Donald Trump was against it
and I think that the coveted era uh
amenities
it's weird to consider that an amenity
it's just like something that should
happen anyway
um was was truly beneficial for uh you
know the the democratization process if
we want to call it that more people
voting more people participating in
elections
um I think that was a big component
obviously the fact that they overstepped
their boundaries on uh abortion yeah
that backfired on them in a dramatic way
in an understandable way any state where
like abortion was on the ballot like
Michigan
annihilated Wipeout yeah why they knew
that this was going to happen they knew
this because they knew it was happening
in Kansas it happened in Kansas before
the in the midterms it happened in
Kansas so they desperately the
Republican party was desperately trying
to get the uh constitutional like
abortion protections uh off of every
ballot they possibly could but they
failed in Michigan and you know that
Drew a lot of people to go out and vote
right because people are going to vote
for something it's actually it's so nice
honestly I I was expecting to just get
annihilated to lose House and Senate and
just live in another [ __ ] Dark Age
you know but it's not one of the Dark
Ages we're not out of them it's
encouraging though it is nice to see
actually some good news coming out of
this and and people also rejected the
stop the steel people all the candidates
most of them all the Maga endorsed
candidates I mean Trump took a fat
[ __ ] L dude yeah and and and you're
seeing it already we have a whole
section in here of Republicans turning
on Trump they're saying it's time to
move past Trump here's the issue
this is not a Donald Trump issue this is
a Republican party issue here's why the
Republican Party cannot run on
Republican policies especially now why
because Republican policies are
anti-populist they're Technical and
their anti-working class right so they
can't show their open disdain for the
working class when they have basically
presented themselves as the working
class party but there's only two two
methods in America to present yourself
as a working class and this is pretty
Universal too at this point they do this
in the UK as well Boris Johnson was very
effective at this you're racist and it's
racist to be working class and the
working class just means why working
class and the more races the more
conservative you are socially the more
working class you are this is like in
the air a lot of people for some weird
reason genuinely hold on to this
narrative okay they think that this is
the truth it's obviously not the truth
the organ class is unique it's diverse
there's you know black people in the
working class there are women in the
working class there are LGBT people in
the working class yada disabled people
um
and then the second way that you could
present yourself as working class is by
left-wing economic uh populist messaging
but that is antithetical to the
Republican party's messaging because the
Republican party wants to deregulate and
they want to make uh they they want to
add tax cuts
Social Security immigration fear they're
like we're trying to save your jobs
people
so this is like I said this is that we
are there in my assessment the
Republican party is suffering from its
success right because they have been so
powerful on Wedge issues on the social
conservatism side and because they've
actually allowed
um the the uh White Evangelical base to
taste the fruits of their labor in the
form of uh you know overturning Roe v
Wade
they now can't use that as a weapon well
it used yeah exactly the abortion issue
they used to use to drive people to the
level now as that's gone and now it's
actually a in the Democrats position
where people are going to the poll to
legalize abortions they took up fat
there is an L in terms of voter
motivation there is no confusion there
anymore maybe you could hide behind like
bureaucracy or trap laws or whatever the
[ __ ] you wanted while simultaneously
offering the white evangelicals in the
South a very active participating voter
base within the Republican party you
could offer them something by curbing
abortion rights but now at the national
level abortion is always historically
been popular to protect 75 across
history right
um at the national level everyone now
knows the Republican party across the
board is associated with those psychotic
Christian zealots that stand outside of
abortion clinics right that's a really
bad look so you have two different
categories within your voter base you
have the Maga guys who make up a big
trunk probably the largest chunk of the
uh voter base the the guys who are like
super geared the demon Hunters you know
the people that go to the parent
teachers conferences and they're like oh
they're Trans in our children the the
Nazis the the working class folk that
are just completely brain broken by
watching Tucker and Fox News and whatnot
and then you have the Suburban voters
who are like I'm fiscally conservative
uh I I'm a little racist I'm racist I
just wish that they wouldn't be so
Brazen about their racism
those two are at a contradicting Point
those two uh voter bases are at a
contradicting point because like you
can't you can't Captivate both of them
at the same time in the same way Trump
did in 2016 because he was running
against Hillary Clinton and everybody
[ __ ] hated Hillary Clinton so now you
have to figure out a way to both win the
primary and the only way to win the
primaries by going right
okay and then not go so far right in the
primary that you have pushed away the uh
General electorate the broader
electorate that that you need to to have
like a winning solution the Suburban uh
you know Karen's and the wine moms and
and you know the racist the white women
and you think that uh DeSantis or Trump
is gonna get it because I me and Dan
been talking about I am so fired up bro
for this um
for this upcoming presidential the
DeSantis vs Trump Showdown is going to
be spectacular dude is going to be so
entertaining and so fun yeah I agree
there's gonna be a lot of tea there I I
think Donald Trump's already started uh
blistering uh
sanctimonious yeah he's not that was
that was not his best no no he's gonna
he's gonna Rhonda is the stinky I think
run to stinky Rhonda stinky run the
neckline we love it folks
um he's so problem is Ron DeSantis looks
like a [ __ ] hero right now they love
his ass he he went from but once Trump
starts bullying him the perception Chase
he's gonna Jeb Bush his ass I don't know
well I'm I'm on the edge of my seat I
love it man I I don't know because Ron
DeSantis is like very good at
gaining National prominence by doing
Trump [ __ ] but the national Republican
party knows he's not Trump as in he's a
political machine guy so he will abide
by the wishes of the Republican Party
Donald Trump on the other hand flies off
uh you know if does whatever the [ __ ] he
wants to do and I'll tell you what if
Trump loses the primary he's not going
to concede bro he's going to tear that
whole party down I feel like we shall
he's going to be a Democrat he's going
to endorse [ __ ] Joe Biden we shall
see It'll be very Joe's a good man
uh I am afraid of uh I've known Joe a
long time he's a good man we've golfed
together
a lot of people don't like Joe but he's
a good man
just totally flops anyway
let's so what I wanted to look at is
some of the hardcore coping going on
amongst our uh I love that conservative
contemporaries
uh oh by the way my side note is that
actually
this would have helped Joe Biden a lot
but the reflation report came out today
oh yeah favorable it's going down way
more than people expected Market is up
five percent that's insane for one day
that's like especially especially like
uh you know important goods for survival
like food down like two three percent I
think it's crazy that's just such great
news I mean that that's that's really
good news it just is and again five
percent that's nuts dude in a single day
so I mean it's still way down from where
it was but he did it Joe five percent so
that's great news so let's start with
Tim Poole uh Tim everyone should have a
nuke pool
um first of all look at all these
leading up to the uh he's so good
election just the best look at his
thumbnails Democrats Panic after mail-in
votes fall short signaling massive
geodes like why where do you get that
information from it's like the
quartering they lit you could just make
up [ __ ] say anything you want and put
it up okay don't diss him that hard I
don't know quartering's thumbnails are
pretty insane bro yeah I mean quartering
does that for like culture War [ __ ] at
least like Temple I like quartering more
than Temple I'll be honest really
because Tim Poole is like
he's such a [ __ ] he takes himself so
[ __ ] seriously yeah and I just
despise his stupid little [ __ ] shtick
is he's such a grifter at least
quartering's like I'm a big fat stupid
inbred [ __ ] oaf and and I'm
presenting you with that and we I
appreciate that you know I mean I think
they're both very dumb and very bad oh
you're just mad because of these recent
thumbnails on you bro
Hassan has dark Jack murphy-like past
revealed
what is this twitch communist attacks a
fan at twitchcon for asking a question
about what the [ __ ] I've never this is
quartering did that yeah
that's so funny and then and then this
one um oh he made you like look like an
islamist
oh that's pretty wild actually that's
cool yeah twitch Mega star male feminist
gets roasted this one says twitch
communist Hassan attacks a fan at
twitchcon for ass oh I know what that
one is they're such [ __ ] that's such
a funny thing to get upset about and
then like present in that way because
like in that moment it looked like it
looked like Twitter fingers did not turn
into you know a real life altercation
for the people that were like trying to
agitate so they like desperately were
trying to flip that around flip the
narrative around and regardless of what
everyone could very clearly see they're
like oh no he was actually owned
actually and it didn't I didn't look
like a pathetic little baby and and uh
no he he was owned in that circumstance
that's why I'm so envious in a way of
what quartering and Temple do because
you can just make a title and thumbnail
of [ __ ] anything even talk about
something totally unrelated for 10
minutes and just get the views this dude
I wouldn't [ __ ] despise that I would
[ __ ] I could not stand having an
audience like that I would I would
probably kiss myself
if that was my audience you would kiss
yourself yeah you know what I mean I
don't know if you could say oh is that
what you would say okay well
wait wait Yi long responded wait wait
wait are you serious Zach yeah we
offered him a thousand Yuan and then he
uh said uh in Chinese uh buy I don't
care about you dude we lowballed him and
then he said forget it don't waste each
other's I keep asking give me a price
give me a price this guy is or something
dude okay okay let's try again let's try
dude he is such a business wizard okay
let's do 2 000 Yuan how much is that
[ __ ] destroying right now okay let's
try 2 000 Yuan that's 300 bucks oh my
God he's owning you bro bye I don't care
about you by the end of this by the end
of this he's gonna have the three
billion dollar studio and then he uh
he's gonna be able to buy Twitter after
this and then he deleted all the
messages from our chat I guess you can
do that in telegram is he just bailed
like for real well he's still talking
yeah dude 2 000 Yuan uh best offer best
offer it's just like a 10 minute call
Bro 2 000 Yuan okay
that's you look desperate
I am I mean you should have came with a
better offer dude what for what he's
calling him for 10 minutes
[Music]
well you think you think I should offer
more than two thousand Yuan that's 300
bucks
what the [ __ ] you do to deserve that
uh he is just Yi long Ma I'm I'm in awe
of the words that are coming out of your
mouth all right how much is 10 000 Yuan
take all my money ten thousand Yuan
tickets that's 1400 I'm not giving him
that there's three HD production is
bankrupt
I'm not giving them I love his ass but I
ain't giving him more than that let's
see what he says to the 2000 2 000 Bro 2
000.
yeah someone says around 250 yeah so so
that's what 2000 yuan is is two is three
hundred dollars basically so all right
let's get back to these losers though so
anyway Tim Paul new Production shows
insane Red Wave coming Democrats are
freaking out Democrats panic over
blowout loss as safe blue areas now
expect to flip GOP Governor admits
they're being destroyed by GOP as Red
Wave blooms that's funny because Gavin
news from one by like 30 points Gavin
Newsom is one of those locks where it's
like you don't even need a projection
like they
his hair
beautiful hair there is no no there's no
contest yes my brother called me uh he
has not had access to the internet but
he's been around like old people for the
past week like his internet is like uh
patchy and he was like so what's up a
lot of people are saying Nancy Pelosi
lost her seat what
bro you're crazy
insane yeah dude Nancy Pelosi
I saw a clip of Tim saying that this is
like he saw this coming I thought that
was in the dock but I don't see it
if you can find that
yeah he went on the show and he's like
uh
I don't know why everyone's uh surprised
by this
or maybe it was a tweet where he's like
this was a good turnout anyway here he
is uh yeah it was a tweet the day before
the uh
the the prime or the midterm and he is
dude this is awesome he's praying we
literally have gone back to like
Medieval Times bro he's doing a rain
dance right no this is straight up like
he is a medieval peasant okay like oh me
Lord the blood moon signifies we must
sacrifice our first born for the Harvest
like that's what that's what Tim pool is
on which is way cooler than like you
know Nate silver being like Oh my God
it's gonna be a blowout Red Wave like
shut up Nate at least this is like Nate
did not hear about the blood moon
because that would have yeah that would
have altered his calculations but here's
Tim Poole uh saying that the blood yeah
they literally are like Dark Age
peasants okay yeah which is cool as [ __ ]
absolutely level two a.m Pacific
Standard Time
when the entirety of the contiguous
United States enters November 8th he's
so
seriously a total lunar eclipse creating
what's called a blood moon lunar eclipse
yeah it's also the day of the full moon
ominous
put it quite literally the red moon many
say signifies the coming Red Wave when
Republicans will sweep God is a
republican as you well know and he loves
the color red so sick God has made the
moon Maga in honor of this midterm
election I'm constantly I'm constantly
living in a world of contradiction
because like on the one hand I think
it's like really fun when people lean
into their schizophrenic Tendencies like
this but also on the other hand I'm like
oh my God they're like literally making
people in his domesticism he's a
mysticist they're making people insane
and at a certain point we're gonna get
to a certain point where it's not just
gonna be like 1.7 1.8 million
pennsylvanians voting for a guy like
Doug mastriano it's gonna be more than
that and I am thinking long term this is
unsustainable okay you think so because
I thought this was a like a rebuke no
because you're not looking at the other
side of this the other side of this and
this is what the Democrat guys do all
the time they're like oh we put up we
propped up with the Pied Piper strategy
we pop we propped up some election
deniers we propped up some like
anti-democracy zealots we propped up
some Christian nationalist fascists and
they got owned because you know the
Suburban uh wine mom said no that's too
gnarly for me I don't really like that
you're kind of gross I'm gonna vote for
civility which is what they vote for
what we are failing to comprehend here
is that
depending on which way Fox News goes
those people are inevitably going to be
radicalized into believing that [ __ ] as
well and that's what I'm feeling I don't
know every time you prop up these sickos
you got more people voting for them on
the Republican side and that is
terrifying my my relief in all this is
that it seems like that's not what's
happening but I guess we'll see here's
Tim Poole after all those videos
foretelling of the Great Red Wave he
tweeted out it's funny how Republicans
won DeSantis Abbott and Kemp won handily
224 House Seats projected and yet I see
leftists mocking the GOP as if they lost
and conservatives lamenting the results
the forecast was so bad for Dems the GOP
winning is uh this is the GOP if you're
talking this well is considered a loss
is he talking about Ben Shapiro when he
says leftist because uh honestly Ben
Shapiro has been destroying uh the
Republicans Republicans I see them
everywhere everyone's like a huge loss
dog pool is the only one who's like I
told to that blood moon bro
it's supposed to be crazy this is like
literally a historic upset yeah it's you
know what I mean it's coping this is
like when the Harlem Globetrotters loses
and everyone's like what the [ __ ] the
Washington generals actually play ball
like what's happening like this wasn't
supposed to happen actually I want to
continue this blood moon video though
because people take Tim seriously and I
think it's important people know that
he's actually just a minute
the midterms of the Blood Moon
I I love this story
me too I am not an atheist I am not
particularly theistic I don't follow any
organized religion but I gotta tell you
when you see stuff like this you can't
help but believe there is something else
out there it is it's a [ __ ] yes he's
right he's right dude he's right he's so
stupid because like you have to be so
um ethnocentric to believe this it's
just like red it's an arbitrary color
that it's communist for the rest of the
world exactly it could be for the rest
of the world it literally me for the
rest of the world outside of the United
States of America red is historically
Associated withly so I mean so by the
same if you want to use the same logic
that read is some symbolism it'd be way
more likely that red means that you know
communism is bad yeah yeah there's a
there's a spirit there's a specter
haunting uh the United States it's the
Specter of Communism but like I said
he's gonna do like I want him to like
really lean into it like do like
ritualistic Shaman sounds like this is
like a [ __ ] Pagan you know let's kill
some habits yeah drink their blood just
like sucking on the neck of a rabbit tin
pool like oh
this boat's not so well for the
Democrats I believe this is how um
bloodborne started is that right then
he's about to hit up he's about to go
gobbling on things yeah not just chaos
order exists because this is give me
some creepy music Zach I think that will
I think that'll add a lot yeah it's
crazy moon
that's crazy
that's crazy what if this signifies dark
days
I don't know
how about we be a little bit more
optimistic than pessimistic and say it
signals a cleansing
that there's going to be a shift
Republicans are going to come in they're
going to wash away this would you say an
ethnic cleansing
yeah do you know positive things like
that posi Vibes keep up posi Vibes let's
think positive here guys for the next
two years will be a process that the
omen is not for those of sound mind and
good judgment those of honesty The Omen
is for the Democrats
who lied cheated and stole their way to
power what maybe I didn't know Tim was
an election denial oh dude she
definitely is well come on maybe this
sign is that's how the 49 State
Landslide didn't happen yeah yeah like
because Democrats cheated no I I love
this accountability
okay so God is spending the funny the
funniest part about this rhetoric in my
opinion is not that he you know sounds
like a [ __ ] medieval peasant but also
the fact that he thinks like the
Republicans if they
gained control over both the House and
Senate would actually do something
productive with that like he thinks no
they were gonna like they were gonna
impeach Biden probably successfully by
the way somehow like after 11
impeachments they would have like a
hundred different Hunter Biden
investigative commitment yeah we found
another laptop you would literally see
Hunter by like there would be a one
dedicated to his penis alone like every
Everything the hunter Biden did uh
committee time
yeah but they weren't going to do
anything with the with that power
another clip of Tim uh resurfaced during
the uh 2020 election he had what is
probably the funniest take ever he
predicted a 49 perhaps 50 state bro
Landslide lost California wrong
Democrats cheated
this is so satisfying watch this
camel and Biden might be throwaway
candidates they know they're going to
get steamrolled in the election I really
don't see the Democrats winning this I
think it's fair to say Trump's going to
win re-election I think Trump might have
a massive massive Victory a lot of
people still watching I think we're
looking at a trump Victory man Trump
said this man clearly has literally no
insight to the point that he's trying to
read the moon okay why do people watch
him what do you mean he's he's first of
all people watch him because he's hot
okay he is sexy because he's [ __ ]
sexy I'll just say it I'm not afraid
people are like damn I want to be like
him how can I be him you know they look
up to him in that regard so that's
number one number two
um he's just soothing like he's
literally
everybody wants to hear from quote
unquote the opposing side uh you know
agreeing with uh their world view Tim
Poole has been able to somehow maintain
his like Centrist presence because like
the [ __ ] that he talks about and the way
that he covers the news comes across in
a Centrist way I guess to like political
normies who are dumb but then like they
kind of see his videos on the search bar
on the related news tab
and uh that's why people love when a
liberal is like I'm a liberal I'm
Progressive as a matter of fact but I
think Donald Trump's going to win 49
states like every hog in hog Alina is
going to watch that and go that's right
somebody speaking the truth he looked
hard with some sense yeah he was wrong
about the foreign on state thing but I
was still leaving him
they think they think Trump was going to
sweep this thing going on with covet I
think that's what we can expect I
wouldn't be surprised at all if Trump
had a 49 State Landslide
Landslide we may be looking at a Mondale
Reagan type scenario where Trump
landslides 49 states and we may see a 49
State Landslide you can't be maybe a 50
state land I think we might be seeing a
49 states what's the state that wasn't
going to vote for yeah I was just
thinking that Xavier I wonder probably I
mean it had to be New York or California
probably California more than New York
call me foreign California's crime
rudding drug addicts everywhere damn I
wouldn't step foot in that state it's a
dangerous Cesspool boy
anyway here in Texas we lose a power
during the coldest month of the year
every year okay let's keep it a buck 50.
[ __ ] California infrastructure is not
exactly great either on Election Day I'm
covering the midterms I had three power
outages because it was raining okay so I
didn't have any power I'm fine do you
guys have any problems yeah you did yeah
no [ __ ] that's crazy yeah yeah we live
in Texas very well we live in the we
live in the proletariat suburbs unlike
you sir
yeah right you're not proletariat please
yeah in the working class suburbs of
West Hollywood
yeah exactly yeah so Tempo is a [ __ ]
idiot we love that about him uh but here
is uh a Fox News compilation of coping
and seething
um this guy this guy what's his name I
forget his name but I know he Jesse
Waters yeah Jesse Waters
um who is of course a Traditional Values
guy he's the Fred Flintstone if he took
uh clenbuterol
wait what's Clint butyrol it's a horse
asthma bronchitis steroid that people
use to cut with it's like a fat burner
you cut it into steroids it is steroids
you just take it uh as a fat burner okay
you got any not going to spare no okay
you want some yeah I want some I'm
trying to burn some fat bro I will get
you steroids like let's put you on a
[ __ ] regimen for me like let's put
you on a stack Dude You're Gonna Wanna
[ __ ] workout you're gonna be angry
all the time you're gonna be horny heavy
you're gonna be horny all the time
you're gonna be angry all the time
you're gonna want to [ __ ] you're
gonna You're Gonna Wanna lift weights ah
give me something heavy an angrier
hornier Ethan is exactly what this show
needs that'd be so weird though it'd be
funny he's gonna fall asleep humping the
bed again we're gonna come into this
studio with his pants around his ankles
yeah this guy with Traditional Values uh
Fox News guy he actually
um is famous in my life for
stalking
um and deflating the tire of the woman
he had a crush with he cheated on his
wife with her but yeah he got her by
deflating one of her tires so he could
trick her into giving a ride home
it was an intern at the time oh he was I
don't know a man who it was an employee
of his I don't know if it was an intern
but yeah anyway here he is
I can't believe John fetterman Won oh
wait didn't we say we wanted to replace
this Dan with the mega compilation of
him
oh
uh uh I can try and find that real quick
Chris Hayes
Chris Hayes had one
oh yeah down Pull up in the meantime
here's Laura Ingram it was pretty great
going into 2024 the Republicans are
going to be looking for candidates who
are focused on winning not just making a
point or settling a score
so to really change the country we're
going to have to win and we have to win
over voters outside our traditional base
that means young people too
that's got to be the goal for the next
presidential election
the populist movement is about ideas Yes
mine it is not about any one person oh
god dude she is like first of all she
was one of the biggest Trump dick riders
of all they all were but they also if
you remember because I've been doing
this for a very long time Ethan back in
2015 they all despise Donald Trump of
course people forget that these guys
they know what the Trump will ruin will
ruin the party brother Republicans run
to run towards the desires of their base
Democrats run away from the desires of
their base which is ironic because
Republicans base desires are [ __ ]
awful but the democratic-based desires
resemble the desires of a normal
functioning State well anyway she's
basically being like Trump by the way
[ __ ] that guy
yeah and we all knew this whole time
that Trump was a piece of [ __ ] it's not
just like ego and grievance though I
mean it is grievance for sure but like
your entire politics is grievance you
just were not able you went too far you
were not able to [ __ ] brainwash
enough people into becoming psychotic
Christian zealots your base is falling
apart
the more we modernize the more likely it
is that the next generation is going to
be less religious
um there are less and less like
Christians tradcats in this country
every [ __ ] year okay you can't build
a winning Coalition by going after the
most insane people over and over again
especially when you give them results
when you give them results you associate
the national party with the psychotic
abortion clinic Watchers okay and nobody
wants that nobody wants to be a part of
that you [ __ ] lose voters conclude
that yeah
your own grudges ahead of what's good
for the country they're going to look
elsewhere period we knew that
I always knew that yeah she always knew
that
here she is and this was about one of
the words
of trump our Lord and savior we love one
of the worst uh campaign strategies like
always was literally just denying the
election results uh because it was so it
was so petty
like Trump does have a call to
personality if he's on the ballot things
might be different obviously you're
gonna you're gonna you know have a lot
more motivated people to go out and vote
for him but when he's not on the ballot
and he's only pumping people that are
saying that like he he actually didn't
lose uh you know that's that's gonna
really throw off a lot of people and
you're not gonna be able to Captivate a
winning Coalition which they didn't
here's Jesse Waters losing his mind it's
very satisfying look at what happened
let let's say in Pennsylvania I can't
believe John fetterman Won really Dr Oz
is like the lamest most pathetic loser
candidate yeah I have ever [ __ ] seen
if you can't believe John fetterman won
um then you just have never paid
attention to Pennsylvania politics until
like yesterday who would vote for Dr Oz
like even you probably didn't who the
[ __ ] would vote for him well no no Dr Oz
Dr Oz is not necessarily the worst
candidate right he is that's the reason
why he actually performed pretty well he
performed uh I believe I mean he
performs significantly better than dog
mastriano
right because he is a winning Coalition
candidate he definitely does get like
some of the civility focusing uh
Republicans right
the issue is the fetty WAP John
fetterman is Die Hard bleeds [ __ ]
Pennsylvania lives and Brees
Pennsylvania he's not a fake phony guy
he is in many respects the perfect
candidate he is like if you put a
[ __ ] if you
if you were to do like an AI generated
you know uh Pennsylvania uh union guy
that is what it would spit out okay John
fetterman six foot eight lieutenant
governor went to Harvard had a four
parents went to Harvard had affluent
parents which they were trying to hit
him on by the way which was laughable
because which [ __ ] politician hasn't
gone to Harvard at this point uh Tucker
uh let's not talk about uh inheritance
yeah so
hadrich parents went to Harvard
literally left went back to Braddock
Pennsylvania small town a high
population of Black Folk living there
very poor went back to Braddock massive
gun violence happening in Braddock
became the mayor fixed up Braddock like
genuinely put Braddock on the map for
Pennsylvania it's not something that
people are going to forget they're not
going to forget this dude who literally
would take time out of his [ __ ] day
to teach people uh to educate people on
his spare time uh so that they could get
their geds like this guy lives and
breeds Pennsylvania so he was basically
the exact opposite of Dr Oz in many
respects a person who came into
Pennsylvania from New Jersey ew oh my
God I can't comprehend a a worse state
to [ __ ] come into Pennsylvania he's
just a slimy [ __ ] bro anyway let's just
watch TV personality of course he was
going to lose especially if fetterman
didn't have a stroke he would have
[ __ ] destroyed him with this so hard
I didn't watch the debate but I heard it
was yeah it wasn't for him it wasn't
good yeah but he's still John Federman
won
believe it for this guy so abortion was
critical we know in Pennsylvania I did
not see that it was going to be that
critical Oz was not a great candidate he
had a brutal we knew he wasn't a good
candidate the whole time no I I disagree
I think I think Dr Oz was not that bad
of a candidate I'll say it which is why
I think he performed pretty well against
anybody
he is an elitist but he was able to at
least capture the Trump supporters
because he had Trump's backing from day
one you're born in New Jersey able to
win yeah he was able to win the
Coalition of like moderates as well and
Pennsylvania suburbs in a way that Doug
mastriano never was able to to capture
because Dr Marciano is a [ __ ] psycho
right yes exactly the type of psychopath
he's like a Christian nationalist
chewing on the battlefield yeah he's
crazy yeah crazy so that's why Josh
Shapiro wiped the [ __ ] floor with
Doug Marciano but the race between Oz
and fetterman was more competitive
though that crudache video anyway let's
watch primary
in Sylvania and so it all is going to
come down to Georgia runoff again so she
else is about Herschel Walker Herschel
Walker on the other hand is a bad
candidate oh he
oh he's he's not a good candidate he's
he has so many liabilities Dr Oz had
some liabilities as well you know a lot
of Opera research if you're on TV for
[ __ ] 20 30 years oh yeah he drinks on
piss by the way but yeah but Herschel
Walker on the other hand gigantic
liabilities like unimaginable so much
Oppo when there's National when the
national Spotlight gets onto this
[ __ ] Georgia race no matter how much
uh Republicans try to beef up this guy
Georgia voters that went for Brian Kemp
it's going to be a hard it's going to be
a hard sell for Georgia voters who liked
Brian Kemp Inspire because Brian Kemp
was anti-trump and because Brian Kemp
was like fundamentally for uh you know
democracy but like still a republican in
every sense of the word those guys might
not actually go and shift over for
Herschel Walker the argument from
Republicans in this race is probably
going to be the runoffs that are going
to happen in December now uh is going to
be listen we know the guy is not all
there but it's a vote it's a reliable
vote and I don't know how many
Suburban uh white moms and Suburban
white dads who are like relatively
affluent or at least like care about
Civility and Aesthetics I don't know how
many of those guys you're going to be
able to convince to vote for it you're
gonna crush him because people like the
governor there they went to support him
yeah now there's no there's no he's not
on the ballot so there really would be
going for the express purpose of
supporting Herschel Walker who is a
walking a Calamity so I think Warnock is
definitely going into this with a
massive advantage and he did get the
vote here I mean barely but he did get
it no he no it's not barely that's so I
mean it's almost a percent the irony and
I did not know this the irony of course
of uh Georgia having runoffs is Georgia
used to have runoff elections because
white supremacists didn't want a black
person to to ever uh you know gain like
a senate seat
which is why they created the runoff
system so that all the white people who
are racist would coalesce behind the
white candidate
would would go uh and support the white
candidate that's why they started the
runoffs in Georgia which is ironic
because now you have uh you know two
black candidates going against one
another
um interesting to think about even
though Herschel Walker is operating at
the behest of white supremacist let's
get real yeah yeah and you got 88 of the
Evangelical vote despite uh Warren oh
come on come on literally Evangelical
dedicating his life to je evangelicals
are insane yeah okay they're not [ __ ]
they're not voting on Christian
principles they're voting on Evangelical
principles which is like hurting the
opposition they are the demon Hunters
they are the ones who think they're
[ __ ] tendril they think that they're
slaying demons out there going to
parent-teachers conferences and [ __ ]
they're psychotic they've lost the plot
of course they're going to vote for
someone that resembles their worldview
here is a little playlist a little bit
longer
primarily in New Hampshire I mean that
guy got railroaded and if you put up a
guy in in who's running for governor in
Pennsylvania who just got slaughtered I
mean these things have down ballot
consequences that hurts Oz or hurts the
Republican house candidates zeldin did
great
considering this is a deep blue State
Kathy hokel had help from every Democrat
crooked [ __ ] [ __ ] Kamala
everybody came in to save her there's
just not you want me to talk about this
real quick too in New York no no I don't
just want to finish this clip okay
finish it yeah yeah yeah for Barack
Obama and for the clintons there's not a
hate Biden vote that's out there you
know when you go with Trump's on the
ballot there's that hate Trump Democrat
vote people just don't feel the same
passion the guy that they also feel for
other people and we have a problem
demographically single women are voting
for Democrats by 30 points this was my
favorite I wonder why it's such a
mystery why are single women voting for
Democrats we can't figure this one out
it's just such so crazy to see that
37 points and in urban America they're
cleaning our clocks in the cities
cleaning our clocks I'm not saying
anything nefarious is going on but they
are cleaning our clocks in the cities
and we're giving it away
and the fact that these youth voters are
coming and so strong on an off year is
very concerning it looks like they've
been brainwashed we need to send them to
war yeah they've been brainwashed no
dumbass like there's two reasons okay
there's two primary reasons why the
youth are voting in the way that they
did ease of access to [ __ ] voting in
the form of mail-in ballots and also
abortion like obviously they give a [ __ ]
about this you literally undermined an
entire generation when you tell an
entire generation of people that they do
not have the civil liberties of their
[ __ ] grandparents had they're gonna
come out and vote that's not
brainwashing you did that also I think
that young people aren't buying into
this whole like trans scare because they
know they're they're so much more
because uh familiar with these issues
they know them this whole transformation
classmates that are trans they have
classmates that are queer like it's not
it's not the same Panic for them
um my friend osita who I had on
yesterday uh brought up a what was it a
cedar who brought this up regardless
someone I was talking to brought this
point up where they were uh where they
said like a lot of the anxiety of the
Republican Party in the in the anger
that the Republican Party presents as
like political uh policy positions is
actually grievance towards gen Z it's
actually grievance towards the upcoming
generation so if your entire [ __ ]
world view revolves around like trying
to Captivate the older voters which
Republicans voted 65 plus voted by 45
percentage points for the Republicans
right 65 year old and plus 45
uh uh plus 45 points like if that's your
goal then
um if you go too far and you activate
the youth they're gonna [ __ ] come out
they're going to come out and vote I
love to see it man that's what we need
we need we need the young people getting
involved and they are and I love to see
it
by the way speaking of what you said
about fetterment we typed into an AI
generator full portrait photo of a
Pennsylvania Union member wearing gym
shorts and a sweatshirt it looks more
like Tom Segura to be frank but it does
kind of look like Tom doesn't it it is
there I mean it's closing up close
enough yeah it is it is it is
there I love how the ai's like this
dude's bald that's all I know for sure
yeah gosh this new generation is totally
brainwashed because a lot of these
single women are about 37
for Democrats are teaching all of our
younger generations and they're
polluting their minds and then they grow
up and then they're in their 20s and
then they vote for leftists
that's awesome the best part was cut out
he goes you know what we need to do
about these single women we got to get
them married yeah no that's great love
that great brilliant insightful
political analysis also ironic like
[ __ ] on women in this way definitely
is the best way to win them over they
don't know why single women are not
supporting them yeah because there is
like serious hours and hours and hours
of commentary that I have seen
personally of them literally [ __ ] on
ugly single women in new hair with blue
hair that have cats [ __ ] they
literally routinely talk about cat
ladies it's like bro you are the most
unfuckable person says that [ __ ]
unfuckable little haired women Greg
gutfelt and Jesse waters are in a
permanent Olympics to be the most cringe
unfuckable pathetic losers on television
okay it's a weird lineup because there's
plenty of them on Fox News and these
guys are Olympic medal winning
unfuckable goobers and yet they are
talking about uh they're talking about
women in this way it's not like that's
why these people have so much disdain
for you this is one of my uh
favorite coping Clips this is
Roger Stone and and Alex Jones what a
lineup
uh there they have a moment of
self-realization here it's almost like
uh self-aware wolf you know that
subreddit it's like yeah I think we
[ __ ] up I think we went [ __ ] up and
they're like oh [ __ ] we convinced
everyone the elections rigged that's why
no one voted and and people need to stop
stop just counting on somebody else to
do it
I actually think unfortunately the
results last night add to a growing
frustration what disappoints me is the
number of people who tell me that after
the last election they just tuned out
anything politically without paying
attention damn I mean their attitude is
it's broken it cannot be fixed I think
that's what you've been telling them
who did this yeah we [ __ ] up we might
have [ __ ] up yeah it almost feels like
yeah it almost feels like making like
basing your entire political
mobilization around like not mobilizing
for politics or not mobilizing for the
elections is uh not a winning mechanism
uh uh policy is weird
we're all trying to find the guy who did
this
[Music]
have you not seen this show I have yeah
okay uh and hope that they're not
letting boys play girls Sports and vice
versa right right right right that's it
that's right boys
playing girls Sports is not a winning
strategy but they don't know that
they're so [ __ ] Turf brained they
cannot comprehend it it is literally
beyond the scope of reason for them to
think like maybe we should just leave
trans people alone maybe I think they
see the reaction and they like it and
they're fundraising and they're selling
products and all these hateful bigots
are coming in but it's not a real
reflection of what's happening on the on
the ground so they I think they're
getting like negative feedback no
they're like trans people in mainstream
media used to get a lot of coverage that
was I wouldn't say positive but like a
lot of defensive coverage at the time
when everyone was like woke like oh this
is woke oh we we need to be more woke
right this was like the 2015 era so they
really pumped up that coverage they were
like oh you're being transphobic you're
canceled blah blah blah right that was
like a that was like a popping thing all
the way from like 2015 till I would say
uh you know it started it started
evening out a little bit now we've
gotten to a point where like these guys
are constantly talking about everything
being anti-woke they're constantly like
I want to make sure that you know my yo
plays doesn't have gender oh gender
neutral pronouns on my yogurt when I go
to the store like whatever Potato Head
people got exhausted by and I'm not
saying there's a moral equivalence here
but people got exhausted by uh the the
woke stuff right I guess like the
Normans got exhausted by the woke stuff
and now they are understandably and for
a very long time now exhausted by the
anti-woke backlash they don't want to
hear it they don't give a [ __ ]
um there was a 20 uh there was a 2021
yougov study
that I saw being shared all around the
internet uh yes uh yesterday uh it's a
really funny study uh they pulled people
they were like are you woke or are you
not woke right
and I think it was like 13 said yes I
consider myself vote woke 23 said no I
don't consider myself woke and then like
60 percent was like I don't know what
that means and I don't care and that is
how people are they're like what do you
what the [ __ ] are you talking about like
what is this [ __ ] trans children or
or pissing and [ __ ] uh litter boxes
[ __ ] like talk to me about the [ __ ]
gas prices yeah well that's great what
are you gonna do about it I I was afraid
it was gonna work for them but again
that's just why I'm feeling so
encouraged by the results here it's nice
to see from this folks they're gonna
destroy us you can no longer stick your
damn head in the time yeah so there's
that that one was really good
um
here's one of I don't know what the [ __ ]
this show is but something tells me it's
got to be really popular based on how
ghetto it looks oh dude no it definitely
isn't no shot this is when you're going
to like these strange apps to find like
uh this is like the 1488 uh truth teller
uh guy talking to you know American neon
washed up American Neo-Nazi well it says
conservative daily your daily dose of
Sanity so I don't know this is giving me
high budget you watch this [ __ ] this one
this vertical watching this [ __ ] they're
they're lost they're lost in the sauce
this is exactly the kind of [ __ ] that is
like I think triggering to the Suburban
moms and dads who are like I'm kind of
conservative I would look the other way
if homeless people were getting shot but
also at the same time like you know
don't do it in front of me
yeah I don't want to see that so here
let's see what uh conservative daily
this the daily dose of Sanity has to say
about it I'm still beside myself as I'm
sitting here looking at all the things
that we're dealing with
and I'm I'm saying to myself
how how
the blood the blood moon foretold
how could this happen I I have to I have
to look at this and go Kerry lake is
down by 13 percent
was 70 percent of Maricopa record
reporting told you they can't let her be
Governor she'll investigate they can't
listen yeah these guys are crazy
we can see the fraud in the machines
draw so we can see it we could see it
yes mail-in ballots yes yes yes yes yes
the Eric system shares all these people
and the fraud of stealing people's
identities and putting that in and and
front loading the machines with the SQL
data which I said you could do it showed
it in Mesa County you run the database
right next to the thing yes go off King
whatever the [ __ ] sound like a
psychopath brother no it's the daily
dose of Sanity you make that your
national campaign you're gonna [ __ ]
lose because people are gonna be like
that's gross you're gross you're crazy I
don't want to be associated with that
well Elon Musk the king maker uh he said
I voted for Myra Flores first time I
ever voted Republican massive Red Wave
coming unfortunately
the king maker uh he just didn't pull
through for Myra Meyer Flores says the
Red Wave did not happen Republicans
independent stayed home do not complain
about the results if you do not do your
part
love that chef's kiss that is some
democrat ass [ __ ] right there right this
is my favorite part this is my favorite
part of like the liberalization of
American politics like everyone turns
into a liberal in a long enough timeline
and that person straight up that's a
Democrat did you did a [ __ ]
Democratic party operative write that
tweet for you that is the most like
Hillary clinton-esque let's not look
within let's not [ __ ] figure out how
to win these goddamn campaigns and let's
just the only our base of support no
that's perfect love that dude keep it up
keep it up y'all didn't go to the pools
yeah you didn't vote hard wasn't my
fault for nothing it's not a winning
strategy now the difference between
Democrats and Republicans that like uh
at the top level Republicans do uh
understand how to create winning
strategies Democrats don't give a [ __ ]
about winning Republicans do so they
will definitely I think tailor their
campaign as best as they can outside of
Donald Trump now this was my ultimate
favorite I saved it for last
Stephen Crowder puts forth an incredible
kind of a philosophical question
uh what if we did not do peaceful
transfers can you match this up with
Stephen Crowder's uh tweet that I had
retweeted talking about
the night of the Red Wave before it
happened uh I remember Stephen Crowder
I remember him saying what cities are
the Democrats going to burn to the
ground when they realize the Red Wave is
coming oh that's interesting because
he's the one here suggesting maybe we
should have a civil war every two years
that's that's really straight let's
watch the Stephen Crowder tweet here
here's this just no no let's let's hear
let's hear what he had to say oh okay
once Democrats lose which city will have
riots first Red Wave okay so that is
interesting now let's hear Stephen
Crowders
I'll take that just so you know we
didn't always pull off a peaceful
transfer of power you talked about us we
actually as a nation uh became a nation
because we pulled off the completely
unpeaceful transformation of power you
no longer have power over us right
that's not true by the way there was no
it wasn't a transfer of power it was
like just a war yeah I mean they weren't
trying it's just what he wants though
that's what he wants but yeah he I love
this idea he's like Revolutionary War
brother every two years baby if we lose
it's War listen man if if your game suit
wearing ass wasn't sucking up to the
queen so [ __ ] hard when she died
maybe I'd listen to your words about the
Revolutionary War okay yeah you dumb
[ __ ] they're they're just such
simps for power whoever the [ __ ] is in
an authoritarian position whoever like
triggers the libs shut the [ __ ] up you
have no consistency [ __ ] all right let
me play it let me just watch this yes
exactly the king of England we were like
yeah how about yeah shuck this transfer
of power oh there goes your tea so sorry
sorry about your tetlease your first one
it doesn't make sense I'm dying it's not
funny there is no transfer power in a
monarchy that's what I'm saying the
transfer of power it was just it was
just a it was just a war the war in part
was so that we could start transferring
power yeah
the transfer of power started with
George Washington he was the first there
was yeah he's pulled off a peaceful
transfer of power you talked but you're
a patriot [ __ ] you don't even know what
your [ __ ] American history you fraud
of power oh there goes your key so sorry
sorry about your tent leaves oh and then
like you said that whole Northwest South
End of slavery thing yeah yeah that
whole peaceful yeah whose side would you
be on big head also a transfer of power
that was had nothing to do with the
transit yeah first of all first of all
[ __ ] like your entire fan base
is on the other side yeah okay what the
[ __ ] you're the one who's like we must
keep up the statue of General Lee yeah
property leads an American hero that's
so God damn these people are so [ __ ]
brazenly Robert E Lee is an American
hero anyone who vandalizes or attempts
to move this statue will have to face me
I carry a tiki torch and I believe in
free as slavery I mean I believe in you
know his Heritage not Hey brother but
also Heritage but also you know that's
what happened
so what's up you want the [ __ ] they
them Army of the [ __ ] federal
government to come and raise the South
this time unlike they did last time you
know what I mean is that what you want
[ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] up but again not a
transfer of power it was literally
they're trying to secede from the nation
that's not federal government uh
operating the activating the national
transguard
to just murk and and jail every
conservative let's go baby
at each other from 18 feet away peaceful
exchange yeah not a transcript of the
best so again peaceful transfer and I'm
not suggesting any kind of violent
upheaval over the elect that's not what
obviously but the idea that the peaceful
transfer of power is inherently our most
valued tradition it's not
bro listen you know there's no
disrespect to people that have carpal
tunnel but like if you got carpal tunnel
you can't be talking about peaceful
transfer of power as though like you
know you're gonna go do a violent
Insurrection he has carpal tunnel I mean
he's got a [ __ ] what is he got he's
got a brace he's got like a [ __ ]
wrist brace
from what I know you're asking ain't
working you're not a [ __ ] blacksmith
you don't use that hand you're just
like are you suggesting he would not
make a good soldier no he wouldn't but
he's got straps also he's got a terrible
he's got a terrible heart you know he
would he would die immediately yeah he
would draft he would dodge the draft so
far oh for sure because you know I got a
gun but I got heart problems gonna hide
over here
our our original tradition is rebellion
is violent Rebellion that's why you have
the Second Amendment you may not like it
broga carpal tunnel from the country
clicking
with a mouse you know it's crazy unlike
uh not only the countries you know in
the UK but also they're colonies by the
way they have a slavery basis with a lot
of these countries ours is fighting off
the world's greatest superpower to
become the world's greatest superpower
The Next Century never been done before
or since it's never happened and also
preserving slavery too that was that
other war was quite literally about you
know the preservation of slavery but but
but actually so what is your point you
say you say okay well he's just saying
violent Insurrection like we could do it
it's that that's dope he's like listen
I'm not saying
violent Insurrection but what I am
saying is like theoretically it's kind
of dope I don't know if you remember
this but uh they did try that a little
bit and it was like pretty lame and they
got [ __ ] owned and you actually if I
remember correctly said any candidate
that doesn't run on abolishing the FBI
will not get my vote yeah all right you
remember that because I remember
remember when Stephen Crowder said
literally those words why because the
FBI was investigating Donald Trump not
returning classified documents right
yeah I wonder if Stephen Crowder still
hurts people to go out and vote for
Republicans who didn't abolish the FBI
wait have you heard there's Crowder news
people are trying to get him in trouble
because he said some have you seen that
oh yeah the George Zimmerman one I think
well the thing is like oh all the
conservatives are trying to get or did
get me and trying and
um
apparently he uh Crowder had a heater
yeah he said where's George Zimmerman in
reference to John fetterman uh wearing a
hoodie in his family wearing a hoodie he
was like what a [ __ ] loser like his
entire family's wearing a hoodie and
then said where's George Zimmerman when
you need him yeah uh basically openly
admitting that like it's George
Zimmerman's uh murder of Trayvon Martin
was unjustifiable but made him feel good
because we're also suggesting that so
much murder his whole family yeah so we
were just talking about it in our crew
chat a second ago and after screening it
I don't know if we could even show it
yeah I don't because he didn't show he
didn't do it on YouTube he did it on his
Rumble [ __ ] oh yeah I don't I think
it's like strike territory if we were to
show it oh so so of course he's not
going to get in trouble with YouTube
then yeah right yeah
I
feel like he's gotten so many [ __ ]
strikes I doubt that he can go live well
they wear off eventually yeah no he he's
up on YouTube he's up and running let me
see louder with Crowder yeah he's on
YouTube no but going live is different
don't you need like
no I don't think so let's see I mean he
up oh he'll what wait what what he has
it so he streamed two weeks ago
and he uh he's kind of M.I.A on YouTube
right now so [ __ ] stupid bro look at
this
um
last video uploaded was one month ago
yeah I think I think he's just like
pumping his clip Channel right now
oh he's a clip Channel or whatever I
don't know let's move on from uh from
this though really you don't want you
wanna crack her bits yeah Crowder
business is where he uploads a lot of
his [ __ ] I think now it's more active 12
days bro never mind I didn't have to
think about it dude he bailed bro he's
got a rumble talking about killing
fetterman's family so okay that's a good
place for that
so that's that
um
yeah that's I mean that's basically
that's basically it I mean some anything
else you want to talk about I skipped
some stuff because I was afraid we
didn't have time for it yeah but um
um
we can talk about around DeSantis real
quick love to
um Ron DeSantis one big in Florida in
the previous election he literally
almost lost Andrew Gillum who was like
you know a hand-picked candidate by the
Democratic party Andrew Gillum is also a
black Democrat which is important for
Florida a little bit right
um he barely defeated Andrew Gillum uh
Last Time Around by like 0.3 percent of
the vote and this time around the
gigantic Advantage they have over
Charlie Chris is hard not to recognize
sorry I just he is suspended currently
yeah how was he sick like dude this guy
gets like a strike every month more than
me
yeah it's horrific bro I I totally
missed this I didn't even know this
happened yeah I remember him saying this
Stephen Crowder called Kamala Harris I
didn't want to say it but genetically
generically
wow generically ethnic
I don't even say because I don't you
know what I mean but Stephen Crowder was
interesting because like when he gets
racist with it he like skips three
generations you know what I mean he goes
way back he like he talks about racist
[ __ ] in a way that like you haven't
really heard in a while like like 85
year olds are like damn that's that's
some old school right that's like
rocking chair racism like yeah it's very
very weird
oh this was a good clip yeah
how much I uh I miss Trump and how
excited I am for him this is the best
club the war with DeSantis here yeah
you've endorsed more than 330 candidates
this election cycle tonight win or lose
the results for Republicans
um how much of that will be because of
Donald Trump
well I think if they win I should get
all the credit and if they lose I should
not be blamed at all okay but it'll
probably be just the opposite when they
win I think they're going to do very
well I'll probably be given very little
credit even though in many cases I told
people to run and they ran and they
turned out to be very good candidates
you know he's the best to ever do it man
I'm sorry like bro this is so good I
miss Trump listen if they win I got all
the credits they lose I get no credit I
get no blame no blame
but it's political [ __ ] people are
just like yeah yeah vibes
said it a million times but he's so
effortlessly funny like he's not trying
to be funny he's so [ __ ] funny I mean
he's a piece of [ __ ] and I hate him but
he is funny it's funny this was super
interesting if you go to our
conservative
you'll see the subreddit and full-blown
Trump Mutiny and this is so fascinating
because these are Trump blowhards I mean
since the Donald got banned die hards
are blow Hearts well I guess both no
yeah both yeah they're blue
so here's actually huge these are super
popular posts on our conservative 1300
points choosing Trump over DeSantis for
2024 as political suicide 1300 points
Trump only cares about Trump let's move
past him and let DeSantis have his turn
to spell I love that now they're like
Trump only cares about Trump
you don't say I don't say
a red wave turned into a purple puddle
thanks to an orange man I love that now
they're orange man bad they made fun of
Libs like so hard but you just saw what
you've been painted
DeSantis is the new Republican party
leader Fox News wrote that these are all
top posts on our conservative yeah
they're mad they are understandably very
upset with Donald Trump because uh
Donald Trump's candidates that were
hand-picked were uh so they were
centered around Trump's narcissistic
desires one of the most important one
being that the election was stolen from
him somehow
and uh if you if you do that then people
are going to be like well that's not
you're not really you know you're not
really giving me something
especially Republicans they're used to
voting for people that give them
something and
um
that something is carefully crafted
messaging that over years and years and
over white supremacist systems has been
uh you know the the perceived enemy
right like uh immigrants uh black people
brown people
uh homeless people that is LGBT people
like those are the perceived enemies of
the Republican voter base right
um You can't really swing that to Petty
Donald Trump style Petty Donald Trump
grievances especially if Donald Trump is
not on the ballot
yeah these comments are pretty great I
like Mega message but now I'm having
trouble with the mega messenger oh
oh Trump needs to go this is all on
conservative this was pure blasphemy
only recently ago this they'd probably
ban you and I'm not only on our
conservative but these are uh flagged
users which are conservative surprise
surprise is like the most heavily
moderated subreddit on Reddit they ban
everybody like instantly if you're not a
conservative and they verify users with
those little tags so you can see that
these are the real these aren't trolls
these are like actual conservatives this
is my favorite one he goes president
Trump is claiming to have dirt on
DeSantis and threatened to air his
laundry a few bids for the White House
so it's like he's doing CNN and MSN
NBC's work for them oh yeah baby yeah
here's the reality if Trump is on the
ballot we're talking about a drastically
different uh kind of math okay a lot of
those Santa supporters will go for Trump
it's going to be bloodbath he'll win and
he'll destroy DeSantis
um I think he has the capability for
sure yeah
well that's about it Hassan I know
you've got to uh oh yeah you gotta get
going yep but um thank you for being
here I had a lot of fun and hopefully
this phone won't get taken down I don't
see why I think we're good yeah who
knows man who knows you're the most bad
man in America I know all right well I
accept that title
not as bad as Crowder though evidently
I'm not posting on Rumble yet think
about it dude and one more time uh
ideology.himbo no ideology.shop
r-d-e-l-o-g-i-e ideology try and get
that URL though write it in the [ __ ]
no not that God damn it I.E instead of a
y
it's okay
um you can get the himbo fitness uh
merch
waited to end soon nope that's wrong
it's okay don't worry about it all right
you got it I'll put it in that I'll put
a link in the description tomorrow
hell yeah hell yeah brother I want some
too I didn't even get hooked up bruh
I'll talk to my Merchant I want that
Union made [ __ ] dude hell yeah it's
different
this is very comfy I'll tell you that
much very cozy I've heard zero
complaints
black sail a Black Friday sale Teddy
fresh up to 70 off go [ __ ] check it
out we'll be here tomorrow for after
dark's gonna be fun I'm about to get my
hair done
uh so stay tuned for that I'm excited to
see it's gonna be pretty crazy
and um well thanks Hassan that was fun
nice to see you and uh we'll be back uh
next week
so anyway and so then I said
[Music]